when i typed in john fitch
um when i was putting the tags in the
video you know how google or youtube you
know starts to recommend like other
search items or other video topics it's
like you know it goes john fitch you
know
mma john fitch ufc then it goes red pill
so like how did you get into this red
pill space
it's a divorce so yeah 2000
end 2017 life's like you know
uh i'm just not happy
i love you but i'm not in love with you
sort of thing 100
what is love yeah well [ __ ]
and um yeah i just went down that road
and
i'm very i'm an athlete i'm analytical
so i look at things i look at
successes and failures and i break them
down and i try to figure out what's
going on
and um i was already kind of on the path
of you know being a creator
and taking my my knowledge of fighting
and and technique and
fitness and stuff towards you know
youtube and doing more stuff online that
way
uh which got me interacting more with
other creators
and following more other creators and
that it got me on a path of
um being more positive
because i felt i felt like my twitter
timeline was very negative and political
yeah i started following more positive
people like ed lattimore
he was he was somebody who uh had super
positive man
yeah super positive things to say and uh
you know it's kind of like you know the
the five people you surround yourself
with
it's kind of like where you're gonna
like the the things that you're
consuming
also you know if consuming a bottle of
nonsense and
ugliness like then you're you're just
gonna have that with you all the time
everywhere you're going
so a lot of people complain though that
the red pill is um
is very negative and misogynistic and
you know blah blah blah
like it's because they're still they're
still married to their blue pill
ideas they still want if they still want
the fairy tale to be real
yeah i think i think the vast majority
of the population still buys a fairy
tale
it's hard like they they you did at one
point right
a hundred percent 100 percent like i
have uh
i've kept journals for a long time and i
released one book as book one
it's supposed to be the first in a
series but like where i
release uh those journal entries and i
write reflections on them
now i'm getting into stuff like i have
to take a break because it's like too
personal
and uh there's a lot of stuff you know
i'm looking
back at and now i have that red pill
lens and
and uh some of the stuff you kind of
understood
as a kid or growing up like
behavior patterns you recognize them but
you're constantly like oh no it's
supposed to be this way it's supposed to
be this way and you think you're bad
because
you're noticing how things are and
you know reading through those journals
like there's effects of it i could see
there was a red pill
underlying there but you you try to
force yourself
into this this good good boy societal
box i guess
do you end up journaling daily like
morning and night or is it a weekly
night for you or i did for a long time i
was i was a
part of my fighting obsession okay like
recording and
just documenting everything and um
like yeah what i ate how how much i
weighed like what my workout was that
day
everything uh yeah yeah that's like a
bit obsessive but
um yeah so
i think going through the uh the divorce
thing got me
looking for knowledge so i'm following
different people looking for different
uh outlooks more positive outlooks
people are looking to grow
and and and learn and make more money
and then i stumble across i think uh the
game
is uh neil
right as far as a fighter okay i wasn't
the fastest strongest
guy out there but i could out thank you
and i could use technique to
lure you into my traps so the idea of
this pickup and the stuff they were
doing it was all just technique
to me it made sense technique makes
sense so
look down that path even more
more red pill stuff rational mail and uh
more and more stuff online jordan
peterson
books yeah i think
i got to a place where i was like this
is
a problem that not enough people are
aware of what
reality is and how much of this
kind of blue pill mindset steals from
you and a lot of it is
really a theft of
power i think from a lot of men are
are most fighters pretty plugged into
the blue pill like are they mostly
like blue-pilled alphas i think a lot
yeah that's a good way to put a lot of
blue-pilled alphas because you don't
even see a lot of them who are like
trump supporters
or uh you know paulson europe supporters
in brazil or
you know but they'll still they'll still
stand for
for feminist stuff got it was it the
was it the actual like like
the wife giving you the i love you but i
don't love you talk that that started a
red pill you're or was it like going
through the divorce machine after it
like
what what was divorce like for you in
california because i mean that's a
pretty hostile state you know towards
fathers
right yeah oh she i mean she was
she used lube okay let's just say that
she used lube in the
divorce rate okay
[Music]
well at least that was kind of her right
yeah so i'll give her that she used it
it could be worse 50 percent
you know cussy the kids so i'm not
getting hit up for or
uh um child support
um the uh
no alimony because at the time like i
was thinking about retiring
so like it was she was just started
working so it was possible she she could
have
paid me out money so she was okay with
signing off on saying no alimony
so that that went in my favor uh
stay-at-home mom or she was staying home
body stay-at-home wife but not a mother
there she was at home but she wasn't
like
doing them she like she wasn't doing the
mom stuff yeah like i was double dutying
a lot of things
did you guys have a nanny too or no
really so like you were
you're playing parent plus you know the
income murderer
i was training for a world title and i
would have to stop
in the middle of sparring around and
change a diaper
really and then jump back in and finish
the round
and she didn't do that for you she
wasn't like john you go chase excellence
i got this
nope she was at home checking out
instagram or whatever
and then i would come home from that
and i would need to i'd have to make my
own lunch so i'd have to uh
rest and then she would take off and
leave and run errands or
get her hair done or whatever
you not like taking a title have any
impact you think on
you know the marriage and her wanting to
bounce um
me getting dropped from the ufc yeah
okay so it was around the same time as
that
i think her attitude changed a lot well
i mean like
me she was not on favor not a fan of me
pushing back against ufc she wanted me
to shut up
and be a good boy and just suck dana's
dick just do what he wants
like she's like she took their side
yeah that's that's not good yeah she
took she took their side in the
situation
and that was kind of like some of the
first like oh really
that's your attitude it was more
important for her to like
get the money and be in the scene than
it was for like
her family to like not be robbed yeah so
we've got playing to win and we've got
playing not to lose and women typically
play not to lose right
so that was that was that's what she
wanted you to do don't rock the boat
john
yes you know so then yeah so a lot of
that was you know then
money changed my job status changed uh
my social circle changed
um a lot because i'm not i'm not going
to hang out with people in this
you know that are going to that thing
and doing those things um
yeah so that was that was a big part of
it and you know
part of me too like i think through my
journals and see like when the when that
happened but there was a point where i
was like what am i doing like why am i
putting so much effort into this
so i like i stopped doing [ __ ] for her
and i focused on me and the kids
at a certain point and uh
yeah i think it'd be interesting to go
back and see when that was it could have
been around the time when i was like
we were hurting for money we had got a
new place
and uh i was gonna sell my truck i love
my truck
i wasn't gonna get much money for it and
i came home one day
and i was i found somebody to buy it and
it was well under what i was hoping to
give for it
and i came back in and and i walk in the
house
and she'd like drop like 500 bucks on
nails and hair
and [ __ ] that day and i was like
what the hell am i why am i giving up my
truck
like why am i giving up something i love
she's not giving anything up
and like we're struggling for this money
so like whatever i was like no
i start putting premium gas in the truck
but it sounds like you're better off
today than what you were when you were
married man
yeah i am but yeah it still stings like
especially
like i was in a bitcoin early and
me being bullied and harassed by her
because it's not a real thing and you're
wasting time and you should
have a real job and blah blah blah like
i stopped trading and stopped buying
bitcoin i was hundreds of dollars at
that time
if i if i would have focused on me and
money and muscles
i would i would have been a billionaire
right now
you